[Music]
Caitlyn Jenner is on on the show today
our first show and she really does she
still has a judgement about gay marriage
she's saying that she's riveted and I
said you're wanting people to understand
and accept you this is like really
confusing to people and you still have a
judgment about gay people in marriage
and like integration she said if the
word marriage is that important and I
was like it is because that's the word
like we want the same thing everybody
well here's a person on TV crying that
hey I want to be myself I want to be
genuine I want people to ridicule me and
then says in the same breath she gay
marriage I don't get it you know it's
it's remarkable did Caitlyn dance with
you uh no she didn't dance I don't think
she's a dancer and she didn't and she
maybe she didn't want to dance with me
because I'm a lesbian I think she I
really think that she and she was great
it was a great interview and I a new
Grateful head and I'm grateful that she
was on the show and and I don't I don't
really know her and I'm trying to
understand because I don't fully
understand it either but I also want
everyone to be happy so but I I don't
fully understand all of that but I want
her to be happy which is what I want for
her for me you know what I mean yeah it
just doesn't make sense that someone
wouldn't even understand that I
that's the thing that's very confusing
about the show because she still has
that that conservative underlying
philosophy on top of all of this
yeah she's Republican and conservative
and and so and I think you know a lot of
Republicans are wishing she wasn't
Republican yeah I know they could get
out